[Music]
I got a call from a really sweet woman
and they think their house is haunted
you want to be a hero why do you have a
cat to send yours oh
beautiful old house but after midnight
the house Comes Alive see
we're gonna need more help
it's time to assemble the Dream Team
field dark history this place that's
when things
weird
I'm qualified and I can get rid of wet
dye
they're running from something hard
whatever evil this is doesn't want us to
leave surprise
there are
999 Souls yeah but there's always room
for one month
I go to haunts other ghosts that's not
if we don't stop them
we're stuck here for eternity
you're not that scary you're really not
and then you're pretty terrifying can
you turn around just while I finish this
thank you
I can show you what happened but it will
cost you
three dollars what sorry robbery who
said that
[Music]